looking back even to last week and in
the preparation and everything um i'm
going to continue with jalen uh this
week
as as the starter
doug peterson saying what everyone who
paid any attention to sunday's win by
the eagles over the saints already knew
of course jalen hurts is the starter why
in the world would you not name jalen
hurts the starter going forward when the
offense stinks across the board you make
one change
and
it's all different and you have your
signature victory of the season you beat
the saints who are in the fight for the
number one seed why what
what in the world of course you're going
with jalen hurts and you know we talked
about this last night on pftpm because
there was other sound from doug peterson
where he was asked why he was hesitant
yeah on sunday right to name jalen hurts
is it out of respect to carson wentz i
look i i said it last night i'll say it
again i don't get this whole idea of
tiptoeing around carson wentz football
is the ultimate meritocracy if you're
not playing well you get benched or you
get cut why are we tiptoeing around
carson wentz he isn't playing well
enough you get benched that's how it
works it works at every position on the
field you either get it done or you sit
and someone else comes in to get it done
yeah i don't get the idea that they had
to treat carson wentz with kid gloves
maybe that's a symptom of the deeper
problem with carson wentz maybe they've
spent too much time treating him with
kid gloves well i don't think that's
crazy i i think that they probably maybe
have you know rolled out the red carpet
for him a little bit that's what happens
when you're their top two or three pick
in the nfl especially a quarterback you
know they just give you the keys to the
organization here you go you can do no
wrong i mean even you have a bad
practice they'll come in and like you
know just high draft picks can do no
wrong for a period of time in their
career you know you could have a bad
practice and the coaches will come in
and be like oh he was great today wasn't
he yeah i mean i saw those nine mess-ups
but oh man did you see how he did that
one play oh that one play oh okay yeah
that one time i did you know they
they're you're given that and that does
create a culture of you know
maybe where we are now i also think they
make excuses for him a little mike and i
don't want to say excuses because i
think they know they have failed him to
a degree as well i think they know that
and that's why they you know that's why
jason
kelsey stuck up for him so aggressively
last week i think that there's a lot of
people within the organization that
realize that but still having said that
i'm with you like the game is over you
haven't played good in weeks and weeks
and weeks the team looked energized and
jalen hurts did well just answer the
question after hey jalen hurt is a
starter obviously we won the game today
did you see the energy we had on the
field end it right there uh but now you
know we sit here and talk about it a
little bit more
it is an awkward spot for the eagles and
i still can't think of a situation
comparable to this where a guy gets
drafted at the very top of the process
plays well enough to get a second
contract there was no question there was
no dispute there was no why in the hell
are they paying carson wentz like oh
yeah they're paying carson went smart of
them to get ahead of it before it gets
more expensive and then the bottom just
kind of drops out the second year after
he gets the new contract so there's no
playbook out there there's no case study
that they can delve into they are the
case study yeah they are they are they
are what other teams in the future will
look to to figure out how to handle it
if they pay a quarterback who they
should have paid and all of a sudden he
loses his fastball that's the thing
about franchise quarterbacks and that's
why they get treated the way that they
do
there's never a doubt that they
shouldn't be the guy on the field they
are the best at what they do and they go
out there and they do it but if you
consistently can't do it
that's it it's over it would have
applied to peyton manning tom brady
aaron rodgers it applies to patrick
mahomes of course hey as long as he's
patrick mahomes he's playing if all of a
sudden he stinks and he can't throw
straight and he can't make decisions
right and the chiefs lose and lose and
lose and lose and lose he's going to be
on the bench too right i mean
we saw
the the 49ers benched joe montana for
steve young just a few years after he
had won two super bowls and still had
gone to the playoffs every year after
those super bowls so
it does happen at times
you know we've seen it happen john elway
they drafted you know maddox out of ucla
because they were a year or two of
average play and oh gosh so you're right
nobody is immune to it i don't care who
you are and of course there's more
circumstances and situations around
carson wentz than any of those guys with
the nick foles super bowl and all of
that but you know at the very least hey
carson wentz can sit there and watch
that game a little bit and take some
notes from jalen hurts and just go
you know the the the biggest thing from
jalen hurts first off the speed when i
watched the film back yesterday it's
better than i gave him credit for really
coming out of college and it was better
than the saints gave him credit for
going into the game because they did not
have really a game plan for him you know
they spied him a few times but for the
most part mike you know we talked about
it they kind of just played defense like
hey we're expecting the philadelphia
offense well it wasn't all the way and
his speed was
the the he was that was the change of
the game hit the fact of his design runs
his scrambling runs when he dropped back
to pass and then there was nothing there
and he could break the crop pocket and
run there
you know then hitting just the open
receivers that were there and then the
most important thing
is
there was no negative plays in the
football game which carson wentz has
been delivering up for the eagles every
other play it's negative negative
interception sack for seven a loss of
seven whatever
that none of that happened with jalen
hurts he took care of the football
he there was really no negative plays
sacks behind the line of scrimmage
nothing like that
and he helped with the field position
battle and look the game's simple you
know you do things like that the other
team made a mistake or two i don't care
who you are in the nfl you're ripe to
lose a game and the eagles and jaylen
hurts took advantage of that
and uh uh look they have to ride this
now last year they were five and seven
they won four games in a row and they
won the division as we've mentioned i
think we mentioned this yesterday i
definitely mentioned on pftpm they have
two teams they have to jump now which is
going to make it harder but they're on
to something with jalen hurts they got
to let it ride they drafted him for a
reason or maybe for many reasons yeah
look right there was a second round pick
drafted six years ago by the patriots
and what did it do it helped nudge tom
brady to the highest levels that we've
seen from him this decade because he got
pissed off sorry london that jimmy
garoppolo was picked they could have
used that pick on somebody else are they
trying to lay the foundation replace me
etc etc he responded in a positive way
carson wentz crumbled
according to jay glazer it shook his
confidence that they drafted jalen hurts
so hey you apply a little pressure to
the situation it breaks one way or the
other it's broken in the way that hurts
may be the guy and now they have to
figure out what to do with carson wentz
which is something i'm sure we'll be
talking about throughout the months of
january february and into march when
they make a decision whatever it may be
sean payton
and the saints obviously helped
contribute to what happened you as you
pointed out they didn't have in your
estimation a clear game plan for
stopping jalen hurts let's listen to
what sean payton had to say in the
aftermath of the game because some
saints may see that that what peyton had
to say sounds a little familiar here he
is
you know when you talk about uh
preparation and you know yesterday you
started mentioning that you know the
team may not have been prepared is that
mostly just game planning and steaming
or some of that
no listen don't don't listen to what i'm
saying
all right i didn't say the team ever
wasn't prepared i said man we look flat
we didn't look ready to play and that's
reflection on me and that's
it's upsetting
and so i've got to do a better job of
making sure i don't
i don't think we played well in any
phase
i'm watching it again right now
offensively it's sloppy screens the
naked the run game
it looks awful
and defensively
they're still running you know the
quarterbacks outside the pocket
all the things
we didn't want to allow happen happen in
that game
we can't kick a field goal early in the
game two weeks in a row that's a problem
so
that's where we start
refreshing when a coach says that that
it's on him to get his guys in the right
mindset to play prepare them to play
have them ready to go press their
buttons of course it's the coach's job
that's why anytime aaron rodgers comes
out and says we didn't have the right
energy we didn't have the right mindset
today i always say that's a
passive-aggressive shot at the coach
yeah because the coach is the one who's
responsible for ensuring that but
shereen williams noticed something we
had this last night on pftpm
last year in november the saints lost at
home to the falcons 26-9 the falcons
were horrible at the time the saints
were were flying high as they always
seem to do the middle of the season
peyton said almost word for word the
exact same thing it's almost like he's
got a card a laminated card that he
pulls out whenever there's a loss
to a team that they are clearly better
than just one of those days one of those
things i take full responsibility for
not having the players prepared it was
it was almost literally the same script
and uh
i give him credit for knowing when to
say it is on me yeah it's my fault for
not having our guys ready to go he's the
man i mean he doesn't make any excuses
ever it's what i love about sean payton
there's no nonsense with him you know
he's not playing games or anything like
that you know yeah he wasn't trying to
make excuses you know he told you yeah
we worked hard during the week but for
whatever reason we were flat and didn't
execute when it came time sunday sunday
you know i think they fell into the trap
a little bit definitely you know an
eagles team that yeah backs against the
wall the quarterback change
okay man is this going to really work
we're fearful of can we make it work
with jalen hurts we got to pick up for
him and it's the saints coming to town
they're better than us you know all of
those aspects and then of course the
saints haven't lost some since uh
september so they're flying high and
going what come on jalen hurts and the
eagles they're not gonna beat us like
that's crazy and they fell into that
trap obviously and i think you know the
coaching staff did too you know early
the big takeaway i'll take from that is
it just seemed like on the offensive
side of the ball mike the saints when i
watched back to film
it seemed like they just thought oh
we're going to come out and run the ball
and we'll just move the ball however way
we want to you know and that wasn't the
case the eagles defense is very good up
front there they got a lot of big guys
and can stop the run but then like he
said you know you miss a field goal you
throw an interception on a screen pass
and you rush the throw into a crowd of
people and throw it too hard to alvin
kamara you know you make a few mistakes
like that i don't care who you are
you're gonna
or who you're playing you're gonna be in
a tough struggle they came out in the
second half and went to a pass first
mentality and that's when the game
changed a little bit but it was just too
little too late at that point and the
eagles had just you know built up too
much of a lead for them to let the
comeback happen
taysonville was pressured on 39.5 of his
dropbacks that's the second highest
since 2016.
how did the eagles manage to get so much
pressure on
an elusive quarterback yeah a few
creative blitzes here and there all
right just like the screenplay itself
the screenplay was a awesome blitz mike
it was one of those where they brought
two dbs off the edge and then the the
two defensive tackles dropped out inside
the middle so the offensive line of
course is worried about blocking
fletcher cox in the middle and doing all
that and then all of a sudden by the
time they drop out they realize whoa i
gotta try to get out here to get these
guys off the edges too late and that's
what happened taste them hill all of a
sudden had somebody in his face quicker
than he thought and he throw it too hard
but it was a few creative blitzes like
that and
really the biggest thing mike was this
and i haven't seen this since early in
the year the saints o line got their
butts whooped that's really all there is
to it they usually win the war more
weeks than not but malik jackson
fletcher cox brandon graham all healthy
flying around you know that that really
was the the big thing that i took away
from the football game the taysom hill
run game the alvin kamara run game could
never get going because the eagles
d-line kind of dominated the front
the latest word on drew brees health
last night and half time of the browns
ravens game i think shefty said that
brees won't play until he's nearly 100
they haven't gone full 100 rule yeah
with drew brees which which often is a
sign that they're going to ride the guy
who's getting it done until he's no
longer getting it done but i think this
is this is a hedge because the belief is
he's not going to be ready this week jay
glaser pointed that out on sunday breeze
won't be back for the showdown with the
chiefs if somehow the saints beat the
chiefs if taysom hill can get it done
against the chiefs you want to be able
to hold open the possibility of letting
it ride with taysom hill if if last week
was an aberration i'm not ready to say
oh oh he stinks because he had one game
that didn't go as well as the others
let's see what he does against the
chiefs and if he plays well yeah maybe
you don't put drew brees back on the
field until he's 100 and who knows when
that'll be if he'll keep playing well
but it's going to be a fascinating
wrinkle yeah to this showdown i'd love
to see brees versus my homes but hill
versus my homes may be intriguing too
excuse me it could be very intriguing
and you know
the injury drew brees has like you know
as you know it's it's one of those two
like don't rush it back come on saints
you know
you got a chance to win the super bowl
here this year let him get totally back
don't get it to where oh he's 85
back and now he makes a throw and gets
hit and you know the rib cages get
extended or whatever it is and now
you're back to like whoa we might have
to sit him for two games again because
it's strained like that that's a
sensitive area so i would not rush him
back i'm not panicked by taysom hill
he's got to clean up some things
certainly like the screen password like
we talked about the interception mic on
the fourth down you know that's another
one he just experienced not seeing the
field the right way he's got emmanuel
sanders one-on-one with the linebacker
down the middle of the field if he
launched they went for it they went for
a big play on fourth and one he's got
sanders he doesn't pull the trigger i
don't know why
he has michael thomas coming underneath
on a shallow cross wide open for a six
yard completion an easy first down
he kind of looks in that direction i
don't know if he's looking at the rush
or whatever but either way he didn't see
the picture real clearly they should
have got the first down there but what
happened there they fumble and then
eagles went down scored a touchdown went
up by 10 and that was just too much for
the saints to overcome
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports